hey youtubers is Charlie instance
Sylvester McCoy was just caught talking
about a new master in Doctor Who series
8 I thought it was time to talk about
our top 10 choices for the role we
really need to think about actors that
will work well against Peter Capaldi's
more serious doctor and full disclosure
Sylvester McCoy was at a convention in
Newcastle and said that he knew who the
new master was already that means that
easy they're blowing steam or there
really is a new master coming so for the
purposes of this video let's assume that
that really is happening since that
would be a huge deal if it actually is
happening I'm gonna try and do a
follow-up Q&A by Tuesday be sure to
subscribe to get it if you're finding me
for the first time so right off the bat
we need to acknowledge the rumor that
Charles dance who plays Tywin Lannister
on Game of Thrones
has already been offered the role book
readers will know you know why from a
scheduling and production standpoint
that might be totally possible that he
could come on and shoot Doctor Who this
year but please don't post any spoilers
in the comments so let's talk about our
top 10 picks including some of those
rumor people number 10 bill Nike yes he
already did appear in an episode as
another character but the master is
meant to be the antithesis of the doctor
and as we learned in the 50th
anniversary the doctor is destined to
become a caretaker of a museum so it
would fit the matically that the master
would have the same type of job at some
point now he has played several grand
villains in I Frankenstein parts of the
Caribbean and underworld series it's
really as Davy Jones role that makes me
think that he could pull off this role
though I always thought of the master as
a tragic villain as depicted in the end
of time and that's exactly what his Davy
Jones character was I will acknowledge
that I have several vanity choices and
this is definitely one of them though
number 9 Jason Isaacs one of the many
Harry Potter actors on my list I really
liked his lucius malfoy character in the
earlier films you know before Voldemort
arrived and coward him into submission
he has played more vicious characters
but there's something about the
characters in Harry Potter that really
gives them this old-time eNOS that I
feel would really go well in series 8
especially with that first episode back
in Victorian London I always felt like
Doctor Who was a bit of a period story
anyway so all the best Doctor Who actors
also had experience playing period roles
number 8 Emma Thompson Harry Potter
actor number 2 but only by coincidence
Trelawney would be an awful master could
you just imagine
Thompson though is one of the great
leading ladies originating from the UK
and she's at the right age to play
against Capaldi's older doctor she's
mostly known for playing non-threatening
characters and mostly her roles haven't
let her be very evil at least in the
grand sense but I would love to see her
play somewhat analogous to Baltimore I
even picked he-who-must-not-be-named as
one of my choices for a new Time Lord
and there's the precedent that doctor
who has a history of casting several
Harry Potter actors in the same episode
number seven Harry Lloyd who better to
play the master after a Dickensian
series 8 opening episodes than the
real-life great-great grandson of
Charles Dickens seriously Harry Lloyd is
related to Charles Dickens he's also had
amazing roles in Devil's and the
Iron Lady as powerful characters and
he's also one of two Game of Thrones
actors on the list yes he was Viserys
Targaryen crowned in molten gold isn't
it a funny coincidence that he also
starred in the hollow crown the master
is really a creation of the Time Lords
but doesn't he want to be king of the
universe just as bad as facere spots
that Iron Throne
number six she would tell a g4 mostly
known for protagonists and now for his
work in 12 years of slave Igea for
previously had an amazing run against
the Ninth Doctor Christopher Eccleston
in the shadow line so in a meta kind of
way he's had a little bit of practice
capaldis portrayal is going to be very
different than Eccleston's so he'd have
to be a little bit more grand but he
also played a very ambiguous if not
effective villain in Joss Whedon's
serenity I don't think that character
would be passionate enough to be the
master but ig4 is just so good I have no
doubt that he would be amazing number 5
Benedict Cumberbatch for fans of a
certain age or maybe just everyone
Cumberbatch is the most popular choice
for any idiosyncratic character it's
like everyone has their lists of
favorite actors and everywhere in the
world he's somewhere in that top 5 which
is probably why he'd totally never had
the time to do it but picture his
version of the master with the wit and
appearance of Sherlock and the voice of
Smaug the dragon the master really is
like the best genetic blend of those
characters brand evil precise
calculating and terrifying number 4 Alan
Rickman dial it back from that dragon a
little bit and you have a much more
practical villain the third Harry Potter
actor on the list Severus Snape arguably
one of the best tragic violence or
treasure
heroes in recent memory depending on how
you look at it is a really evil roll of
his that comes to mind is his Hans
Gruber from die hard he's admired for it
just as much as he's parodied for it
which is why I think he's perfect for
Doctor Who it's a series that at both
times is beloved in just a little bit
silly usually the showrunner is mostly
the one that informs that second part
the humor of Moffitt's run though is
slowly turning into something else and
if the rumors are to be believed coming
to an end
number three Gary Oldman Harry Potter
actor number four on the list
I sense a trend one of the best
character actors working right now and
willing to try just about anything he
actually said that the main reason he
chose the role of Sirius Black and Harry
Potter was because of his children so
let's all hope that his children are
also Doctor Who fans imagine a blend of
his characters from Tinker Tailor
Soldier Spy and Dracula or maybe just
even Dracula what I'm saying is I would
love to see Dracula be the new master
didn't Gordon tipples master look like
he could have been a vampire too though
number two Malcolm McDowell one of the
most iconic villain character actors of
the last 40 years I consider his Alex
character from Clockwork Orange to be a
spiritual father to Andrew Scott's
Moriarty
if Capaldi almost seems like he would be
Matt Smith's father then who better to
play the counterpart to John Simm than
McDowell in fairness though he is the
oldest person on this list and seems
like a more sinister version of Derek
Jacobi's master and I really think that
they're gonna go with someone younger
and a little more prominent in the eyes
of audiences right now which leads me to
my number one pick Tywin Lannister I
mean Charles dance due to the incredible
popularity of Game of Thrones it's hard
to think of him right now without
thinking of Tywin but outside of the
rumors that he's already been cast there
are so many things that scream yes about
this first the pedigree of evil that
actually sounds like a good title for an
episode he's played several amazing
villains and is mostly known for playing
distinguished characters that is to say
the master will not appear as a fool
then let's look at the perspective of
the BBC they want this show to be as
popular as possible and the best way to
do that is to find amazing actors that
are also incredibly popular for more on
that refer back to my Benedict
Cumberbatch choice right now next to
Walking Dead Game of Thrones is one of
the most internationally popular show
on cable television meaning that almost
anyone who watches TV probably knows and
fears Charles dance imagine a more
forthcoming version of Tywin dressed in
Victorian clothing which opens a whole
new topic of discussion for a future
video
what should the Masters new costume be
and with that I'll pass it to you guys
who do you think should be the new
master and do you believe the rumors
that Charles dance has already been
offered the role like I said I'll try to
get that Q&A video up by Tuesday be sure
to subscribe to get it if you're finding
me for the first time and leave me all
your questions don't forget there's big
stuff coming tonight there's a brand new
game of Thrones trailer just so much
Charles Dan's going around tonight and
there's new Walking Dead right now click
here to get that Game of Thrones trailer
I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it a little bit and click here to
learn all about the new companion on
series 8 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys in a little bit high
fives
you